in the United States the investment
banking giant JP Morgan is set to take
over the troubled U.S Bank First
Republic in a deal brokered by
Regulators the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation confirmed in a statement
that first Republic had collapsed on
Monday making it the third major U.S
Bank to collapse in the last few months
a U.S correspondent Martha Kellner joins
me now from Los Angeles and Martha how
worried is the White House about all
this
yet fairly concerned and I think a
concern shared by The Wider public
people will have woken up this morning
quite understandably seen this news
about First Republic and being worried
about their own money their own bank
because as you mentioned this is the
third major U.S Bank to collapse in just
the past eight weeks following the
collapse first of Silicon Valley Bank
and Signature Bank and there have been
concern after the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank that that would prompt more
Bank runs First Republic knew that this
was a danger they had immediately sought
to reassure customers and investors but
nerves weren't calmed and that became
very apparent when last week they
released their earnings for the year and
it became clear that customers had
withdrawn far more money than Wall
Street expected 100 billion dollars in
deposits in the first three months of
the year and at that point it became
clear that something very dramatic would
have to happen to save First Republic
the FDIC the regulator stepped in at
that point They seized the bank and they
asked other Banks to take a look at
First Republic to see if they might be
interested in putting in a bid to buy
this failing bank and three Banks did so
overnight the federal regulator
announced that JP Morgan Chase the
biggest of the big Banks had brought
First Republic securing most of its
assets and around 100 billion dollars in
deposits the JP Morgan chief executive
said our government invited us and
others to step up and we did there are
more than 80 branches of First Republic
across the United States predominantly
in California and New York so overnight
their customers became customers of JP
Morgan Chase and the Hope in the white
house and on Wall Street is that they've
avoided the same sort of uncertainty and
nervousness
made the Silicon Valley collapse and
that hopefully this will not affect the
banking sector in the same way and
further Bank collapses can be avoided
Martha thank you very much